top gun maverick is the 35 years later
sequel nobody expected but it still
leaves a few loose threads hanging in
the wind like whatever happened to
charlie what does maverick's future hold
and how is this entire team not
court-martialed in the end warning
spoilers ahead
in top gun maverick lieutenant jake
hangman saracen is the maverick
archetype of the film there is no
disputing his talent as a pilot and how
he possesses all the necessary tools to
succeed in top gun but he also holds
many of maverick's most undesirable
qualities as a younger pilot such as
recklessness selfishness a blatant
disregard of orders and well a pretty
punchable face in fact he could be far
worse and more unmanageable than
maverick which one he all has what it
takes to follow me taking into account
hangman's cowboy reputation and his
inability to play well with others why
is he even drafted into a group for the
special mission in the first place
undoubtedly vice admiral beau cyclone
simpson must have read up on his history
to know that he has a propensity to fly
solo rather than as a unit so it's
mind-blowing he would even think that
hangman would suddenly become a team
player in a few weeks sure there's the
argument that his defiance of the rules
is what saves maverick and rooster in
the end but that doesn't excuse the fact
that he has the wrong characteristics to
be a part of the unit to begin with
top gun maverick sees the return of some
familiar faces from the first film
namely pete maverick mitchell and tom
iceman kazansky it also addresses what
happened to carol bradshaw revealing to
the viewers that she passed away some
years earlier however the sequel never
discusses what has happened to charlie
blackwood maverick's love interest from
the 1986 film instead jennifer connolly
fills a similar role as penny benjamin
but what makes this even stranger is the
fact that charlie shows up in old
photographs and in a cringe-worthy
flashback appearance yet no one explains
where she is or why she is no longer
with maverick at this point but i wasn't
gonna leave without saying goodbye it
turns out that kelly mcgillis doesn't
know what happened to charlie either as
no one reached out for her to return for
the sequel that said she holds no
grudges over connolly being cast as the
new love interest in the franchise and
told entertainment tonight she is so
glad that she got that opportunity top
gun maverick director joseph kaczynski
revealed to insider that charlie's
return was never a part of the plan as
the movie didn't want to stay too rooted
in the past
from the get-go it is clear that the top
gun team chosen for the special mission
is probably doomed no one believes they
will successfully execute the mission
objective and get out of enemy territory
alive especially with the risk of going
up against the enemy's fifth generation
su-57 fighter jets and the tricky
terrain however they are given fa-18s
mavericks knowledge and a few hail marys
before they are sent on their merry way
to the danger zone but why doesn't the
u.s naval force provide the team with
more high-tech aircraft to begin with
the lockheed martin f-35 lightning ii
for example is considered one of the
most advanced fighter jets and contains
the next level stealth and sensor
technologies that would be a major
advantage for a mission of this
magnitude the question is would the f-35
handle as well as the f a-18s in the
required environment and under those
specific conditions
one of the biggest plot points of top
gun maverick is maverick having to be an
instructor to lieutenant bradley rooster
bradshaw the son of his deceased former
partner goose instead of focusing on
rooster holding resentment towards
maverick for his father's death the film
decides to take a different approach it
shows how maverick is responsible for
pulling rooster's application to the
naval academy and causing him to lose a
few years of his flying career naturally
this decision causes friction between
the two men later in the movie it is
revealed that rooster's mother asked
maverick to pull her son's application
fearing the same fate would fall on her
boy that had ended her husband's life
maverick never reveals this important
detail to rooster deciding that the
young pilot should resent him and not
his mother for what happened while
maverick and rooster are in a much
better place by the end of the film the
secret remains undoubtedly the two will
have more conversations about rooster's
academy years and one has to wonder if
maverick will eventually reveal the
truth about why he did what he did maybe
the answer will be revealed in top gun
rooster
security at an airfield is incredibly
tight or at least it's supposed to be
not only do pilots need special
clearance and the right identification
on them at all times but there are many
additional layers of security to pass
through before even thinking of taking
to the skies if these measures aren't in
place aircraft could crash into each
other on the runway yet top gun maverick
makes it look as simple as walking into
a hangar picking out a favorite jet and
saluting fellow pilots before takeoff
after vice admiral simpson takes over
the training for the mission and
dismisses maverick from his duties he is
surprised as everyone else to see that
maverick has taken an aircraft to prove
how the mission can be executed in his
specific way not only is this deliberate
insubordination and technically theft of
military property but it also
illustrates that top gun security must
be run by the same people who train the
useless gotham city police department
surely there must be some form of
clearance needed before maverick can
take a jet out on a joyride
in top gun maverick the concept of
breaking mach 10 in other words going 10
times beyond the speed of sound is
introduced on several occasions of
course it is maverick who breaks this
distinguished record and has everyone in
awe at his jaw-dropping feet while it
might sound incredible it is also highly
unrealistic that maverick's head doesn't
pop from all that pressure in the cabin
as a result of pushing the limits one of
my favorite analogies that some of the
top gun pilots have it's like being
strapped on to a dragon nasa's x-43a
scramjet only reached mach 9.6 and this
was considered a monumental event in
flight history more importantly fighter
pilots are only able to withstand speeds
above 9g for a brief second or two
depending on their fitness levels so
there would seem to be no way that
maverick could survive breaking these
records in the movie
across both top gun films one thing is
abundantly clear the rules are optional
for the pilots and there are no
consequences for ignoring them the
pilots put each other and the missions
in jeopardy as they believe they know
better and disobey direct orders from
their superiors now while rule breakers
are common across every facet of life
naval forces are renowned for being
extremely strict about the rules and
protocols it's for this reason alone
that most people don't make the final
cut since obedience isn't just a nice to
have quality here towards the end of top
gun maverick rooster and hangman openly
defy direct orders from vice admiral
simpson instead of being grilled and
court-martialed upon arrival at the base
they are celebrated as heroes for their
actions it can be disputed whether
they've done the right thing but what
does this mean about their level of
respect for simpson as a superior and
his instructions
after maverick is dismissed from the us
navy and redeployed to top gun as an
instructor he is told that it is his
last chance so if he wants to be around
aircraft this is the only option that he
has at the same time it is revealed that
iceman who served as an admiral has
saved his old pal numerous times by
putting in a good word when he's chosen
to ignore the rules while the ending of
top gun maverick leaves maverick in
something of a sticky predicament he has
successfully trained the team for the
mission and the assignment is now over
more importantly with the death of
iceman he no longer has an ally who will
go out and bat for him when he chooses
to disobey instructions and be a general
thorn in the side of authority
retirement could be the only option he
has because let's be honest even if he
stays on as an instructor at top gun he
is bound to upset someone in a position
of power by not following their orders
maybe so sir
but not today
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you